okay welcome to the final video for the
word rapid championships before the
final round round 15 kayaking lead in
Nome with one point ahead of Carlton who
really spoiled a huge lead after day one
add a tube sorry this is day three
already so before the last round it's
pretty simple the only chance for cards
needs to win I'm against a pile of while
kayaking only needs a draw against Grand
Master Kuno Sofia to secure first place
and yeah Duke I atkins game first now to
see what happens in terms of the
tournament when kayaking going deform
and goons of playing the Sicilian yeah
kayaking placer a normal normal main
line here going for a sharp set up not
minding really a fight in this game he
didn't play some yeah drawing line or
something alright so the time man of
variation I'm p5 is a bit a bit of note
of an old-fashioned move but I think so
playable I'm Knight f6 is more common
nowadays with them this kind of stuff
happening but b5 is the traditional line
that 10-man of himself played so castles
there should be seven and now wyd
captured on c6 and played a three so
yeah this is a kind of indication that
why does playing it to bits but on the
safe side here and I think he maybe had
some more aggressive continuations but
no need for excessive risk here you just
need to draw two to win this tournament
so a three to prevent any before ideas
is quite a good move
so black continues to develop and white
goes f4 there's not much else in terms
of active play in this position so
therefore as normal d6 Queen f3 so
they've got this typical third-ranked
set up here and black puts more pressure
on the four point which wider
strengthens with this rook castles and
Bishop deform so I'm quite a healthy
setup here for white one ideas to play
something like this Queen to h3 rg3
depending on the concrete position and
then advance with e5 to unleash this
Bishop and we see some of these ideas
happening but like immediately tries for
counter play which wyd needs to attend
this bishop was attacked and you cannot
retreated sb2 was hanging so this way he
protects the bishop and also protects me
too and now black with a direct play in
the center on this point so wide
advances and black mages to play nitey
form yeah this is certainly quite a good
opening result for black he doesn't have
any specific problems but white is still
fairly solid it's not easy to see how
black should improve his position by a
huge of them to improve it really
considerably play g6 to prevent this f5
idea this white that white might play
and now Knight c3 why doesn't mind to
exchange exchange more pieces Bishop c5
VI know why take the chance to to drop
back and ask like okay what are you
doing you really want to exchange your
good Bishop
versus mine yeah and we get this
transposition now transposition no
transformation sorry to an end game
where this night nicely covers the C 2
square and also this pawn might be a
weakness and it off very logically and
develops 22 quite an equal endgame wyd
might some white made them look better
he at first sight you think that okay
you can win this pawn somehow maybe when
this pawn but black is threatening a
form and this is just just a problem
here white cannot really prevent this so
he decided on 95 to offer repetition
here which black declined but this is
still still a position where black
cannot do much you've got this covered
in this attacked and like after giving
this check one the sea fog horn but
black one a form and not quite sure at
which point but yeah here they decided
to to draw the game so kayaking did a
quite professional job here to wrap up
this tournament with the draw and also
um I think maybe he was a little bit not
sure but maybe a little bit surprised by
this kind of old-fashioned term
variation from blacks point of view and
I think this a three and stuff is not
really I'm the kind of setup to refute
this black do TM so um yeah this is
actually time for congratulations on on
winning this tournament kayaking really
did it as some this draw basically yes
secured the tournament
Carlton even with the wind against
Apollo um yeah wouldn't overtake him he
just lost too many too many points so
kayaking scored four and a half points
um on this final day with some yeah
admittedly some some help of his
opponents but this is always necessary
cannot win without the opponent's making
mistakes okay but to make this a
complete video let's look at Carlton's
game also against Apollo and yeah we're
in for some really weird stuff happening
so let's see what happened in this game
um it starts pretty solidly with the
sloth defense the a6 line siobhan ankle
line white played III and now Carlton
with them slide surprise here Bishop f5
I'm just thinking about this did he
already played this against in this
tournament I'm not quite sure but
usually I'm in this position Bishop f5
is not the preferred move they usually
play either be five or six or come skis
special move here g6 but this Bishop f5
is somewhat somewhat uncommon back in
the day when I studied this one reason
I'm was I think the move Knight e5 but
tapar loss just plays Bishop d3
continuing just his development yeah and
what Carlton is doing here in this game
is really a kind of provocation he tries
to provoke white and doing something and
tries to sort of yeah win-win with
counter attacks or something like this
so it starts with e 6 which is some
certainly playable but the combination
of this structure with a six is a bit
bit uncommon you would see what happens
now why takes and place queen bee three
and now you have a position which is
quite compromised already in the center
and p7 is hanging so he needs to play
rook a seven this looks a bit shaky but
it's certainly a playable but still a
bit of provocation involved so to pile
of Bishop detune and now we captured
even and there should be six
yeah all pretty pretty normal moves um
what are you what are the ideas here
black tries to control the centroid
squares with this pawn on f5 a knight on
f6 and whites idea is to open up the
position with e4 and e5 before this rook
really I'm inspecting the game and I
think this is exactly what happens in
the game he tries to ya quickly play you
form black took and played 97 black I
think would be perfectly all right if
the rook was on a aid so if he had this
movie extra so now it's it just takes a
bit of time to get this piece involved
still it might be okay for black but it
gets tricky very quickly Bishop g5 Queen
a five to control also the square from
the side rookie won all very normal and
now look ahead young a Sri securing some
lift for the king so that you cannot get
background check mated and now Queen B 6
and this is really a provocative move
again to retreat or to move away this
night from the kingside so Lex King side
is really a bit gabadh without defenders
now he immediately try to make use of
this and um it looks a bit a bit
dangerous for black least in my book but
them okay plate 25
trying to exchange Queens and this Queen
also covers nice DDF seven square this
way I'm intending maybe this move well
Blackie always has this answer but yeah
you see that why does really am getting
close to blacks king also this could be
an idea morbid bidam lots of arrows here
this kind of idea it's also all so nice
so you played rook e8 setting for
counter play on the eform and now White
Queen to have six we should look briefly
at this energy for idea I think then
black just drops back the night and
covers the square Y term can try this
kind of stuff it's all forced and
certainly white looks a bit better here
at first sight with those active pieces
but it's not not quite sure I'm not
quite sure if this really leads to
something something great let's say b5
and rook ft 8 not quite sure I think
hitch wanted to wanted to try for more
and went here so I said quite similar
position but with a nite salon here wyd
played the quite obvious move Knight to
g4 he had alternative so I'm like Queen
e7 taking this porn
now maybe maybe also a good option but
94 really is so the kind of normal move
i think carlton with age five not much
else night age sex age six was quite a
big threat so now white am dropping back
and blake playing Queen d8 we can also
check what happens if black takes the
pawn why then could play rugby one and
now blacks queen must sides where to go
if you go somewhere here let's say to be
four then why it has this shot
threatening made on h8 so we need to
take ya know
black cannot survive three heavy pieces
on an open board three attackers is
usually too much for a king you
sometimes can stand two but three ads
usually curtains so black needs to be
careful he might be able to grab before
but then he would need to take here so
that this move is not possible due to
the pin but here maybe this kind of
stuff yeah it's super complicated and
very risky so Brooke b6 now like would
would would would be able to take so I'm
well it's certainly not a move that the
human would play taking on d4 especially
because this pawn this week anyway and
it doesn't make so much sense to grab a
weakness um if you have other useful
moves to improve your position the
weakness might fall anyway so Queen d8
trying to get rid of the Queen's which
wide certainly declined yeah black
didn't want to allow Knight to Queen to
h6 so King g7 is some quite sensible I
and white tries to bring more pieces to
to the attack
yeah this kind of position often arises
in in Queens gambit structures it's some
very often about equal because white has
so some attack on the King and take
activity on the e-file while black has
this quite strong night and this
potential play against the isolated pawn
but very often it's difficult to really
am exploit this pawn as white is so
active and we see in the game that it's
um it's not really happening so much
black just defends but there's still
some some stuff coming up so okay white
regroups the night maybe bring this
piece to e4 to g5 later so not not much
happening really okay rookie 5 so maybe
he's attacking age 5 yeah like attacking
the night and it retreats and Knight to
d7 at this point why cannot take on age
52 just show this quickly because like
an exchange Queens and therefore get rid
of this pin so the rook has really lost
here
so wyd played nygean it's getting a bit
scary now this night on g5 possibly with
sacrificial ideas going to do six and 90
form yeah and now maybe one idea could
be this kind of stuff this age five pawn
is really a bit of a concern for black I
think black probably wouldn't have any
problems at all if this pawn would be on
h7 but ok I'm you need to yeah follow
the Chester words what can you do this
phone is them c5 and now 93 to pile of
really trying hard to to get something
here and black played H form ok look at
the clock times this is important now
they're both at about two minutes left
and now to part of played night age five
this move is winning for white and
therefore you can conclude that age for
was a mistake the thing is Blackwood
could play let's say rookie seven and
maybe there's not so much happening at
least them when I looked at this briefly
I didn't I didn't see anything together
with the computer of course so this this
seems to hold but H 49 h 5 and this is
really yeah winning you know this is
also quite amazing that's actually
winning instantly cars and took the porn
other the night and what's amazing is
that the other moves are really
completely losing I think let's say King
here and then this move is really really
winning instantly black doesn't have a
move
if it takes Queen takes you've got this
thread coming up and on King here you
have rook e8 so black is just completely
murdered here yeah it's understandable
that he took the night so we grabbed it
and now to part of plate Queen takes h5
if you want to do a small kind of
technical exercise you can look at this
position and try to find a good move
here for wide I'll stop here for a
couple of seconds and drink some water
yeah white could have played here look
g5 check if the King goes to the H file
it's very simple direct mate oh no don't
tell me f this mate mate thing again
yeah after the the phenomenon here if I
if I have a check made on the board then
the back button doesn't work just a
second I need to fit I'll ride on back
fix this little issue ok so Queen TX h 5
is a direct checkmate so of course king
of Ages the real thing here and then
yeah why just takes here threatening
queen edge aid and there's simply no
defense so to part of basically mr. made
in three moves here not quite sure what
what he didn't see they had two men and
two minutes left I think usually you
would say like three seconds should be
enough for him really really weird this
is just made so um what can you do you
just miss the maid in three here and
with very really simple moves at the end
he took on age five and now black when
Ruby six and you know you have this
lateral defense IAM and then to really
hard to get why didn't play root g five
okay so wyd played rook g5 check there
were alternative so white can also try
this kind of stuff with the idea of
taking with the rook on h form and this
is also still very dangerous but ok time
both were very low on time so it's
understandable he gets together it's
check and on rook g6 here grab this so
why tum is it's a winning a pawn at the
end of all this but Quincy six is quite
a cute move here because like actually
has some counter play rook takes the aid
there's Queen g2 checkmate I don't put
it on the board because then I maybe
have this oh I I already have this issue
I need to need to look into this why I'm
not able to do too I know it's no it's
gone so funny um the point is what what
I was saying is if white takes here it's
actually black giving a check made so
wyd cannot take on the eight and at the
end he played this funny move because of
course the d8 rookie singing queen takes
rook takes and now black plate c4 very
important to have counterplay possibly
with [ __ ] porn if wide advance is with
this D porn like you
to have this kind of stuff to have
counterplay and funny enough after all
this the skill mesh this position is
maybe around equal black has as
mentioned counterplay we see what
happens white pushes Queen d2 attacking
the rook and keeping an eye on d 60
white doesn't have much choice he needs
to give this pawn and then we see that
yeah here White has a hard time trying
to win black has all this is checks
coming up and still the C porn maybe
this is some around equal he played the
rook takes e4 and this is a pretty
simple draw now here he tried F form
last last bullet so the same but now
Queen III and this queen is just
delivering a perpetual white cannot do
anything to prevent that he played d7
and now black is giving the perpetual
check so quite a funny game here where
to pull off yeah with the double blunder
actually h4 losses this is fine but now
he played Queen a5h five instead of rook
g5 check which is really a super simple
win and quite weird so Carlton could
have easily lost this game and maybe
it's age for was a bit too much of
provocation alright so um this was the
coverage of the world rapid
championships with them the winner Sega
coyoacán surprisingly after those first
two days I think it was the only thing
you thought of okay how many points will
cause an f at the end 13 or how much but
yeah he lost two games a very tough
fight against Yvonne Chaka and um
would you have very difficult game
against greece Chokwe i think just made
a single mistake with this Bishop d7
move otherwise I think he didn't do much
wrong in this game but grew shocked
really prayed played excellently well
yeah in the meantime while Carson was
giving away points kayaking won all his
games and with a bit of luck of course
against Iran shook way was losing at one
point but then even one on the end when
even shook simply forgot to yeah i'm not
sure forgot to place a clock or whatever
he just lost some time in a quite simple
drawing position alright so i hope you
enjoyed the coverage and yeah i'll be
posting a new video soon on various
subjects of course followed by this this
rapid Championships World Championships
in Calais tan is immediately followed by
the word bliss championships I'm not
quite sure if I should do any commentary
on blitz games so I mean I do it with my
own but well let's see if there's some
interesting stuff going on then I might
make a video on on the capital of those
blitz games yeah thanks for watching and
leave any questions or comments of chaos
on on YouTube and yeah talk to you soon
with the new videos I think I'll also
have some stuff coming up with with
games of myself where I played some some
online tournaments but there's also
Dortmund coming up next week where maybe
doing some videos actually this is
announcements I can make I will be doing
videos on the dogmen tournament but in
German language so those German Watchers
and listeners can look forward to not
having to put up with my English so i'll
be doing something in german on this
channel starting next week when the dog
tournament kicks off yeah thanks for
watching and talk to you soon with new
videos